رونالدو كابتن فريق موسم الرياض في مواجهه
باريس سان جيرمان الخميس وازمه عالميه
ومرضى السكر مولاجين علاجهم والسبب
الراغبين في انقاص اوزانهم ووسط كل
الدراما والازمات ال الماسك يتحول الى
طبيب نفسي ويحلل علاقه تويتر بالغضب اهلا
بكم
[موسيقى]
كره حول العالم مو بس مشجعي الهلال والنصر
و فارس سان جيرمان انضارهم رحت اتجه
للرياض يوم 19 اللي مباراه كاس موسم
الرياضي المنتظره واللي اعلن عنها من ايام
فالنجوم فريقيا الهلال والنصر رح يواجهوا
النجوم نادي باريس سان جيرمان على ستاد
الملك فهد الدولي المباراه هتكون الاولى
لرونالدو في السعوديه من وقت انضمامه
رئيس هيئه الترفيه معالي المستشار تركي ال
الشيخ كشف انه الدون راح يكون كابتن فريق
موسم الرياض اللي راح ينافس نجوم باريس
سان جيرمان ولبس
تحديدا رونالدو
يلا الوعد يوم 19 مع كابتن
[تصفيق]
ثان ثان
مع الفيديو الي شفتوه قال انه المباراه
راح تكون لقاء فوق الخيال وكشف انه مدير
الفريق راح يكون كابتن خالد
ويعبر معالي المستشار عن امنيه عنده فقال
خلال هذه الساعتين اتمنى ننسى الهلال
والنصر ساعتين ونصير كلنا موسم الرياض
وبعد ساعتين نرجع نوقف الهدنه ثانيه
المشهد لما يفوز فريق موسم الرياضه
ادي المباراه راح تكون المواجهه الاولى
بين رونالدو وميسي من ثلاث سنوات من وقت
مباراه دوري المجموعات بدوري ابطال اوروبا
والانتهت بفوز يوفنتوس 3 0 وقتها رونالدو
سجل منهم هدفان وبعد هذه المباراه بكم يوم
تحديدا يوم 22 راح يلعب رونالدو اول
مبارياته بتيشرت النصر امام الاتفاق
[موسيقى]
مرضى السكري حول العالم بوجهه ازمه فدول
كثيره في العالم فيها نقص في ابر معروفه
لعلاج السكري وكثر من المرضى مو قادرين
يلاقوا علاجهم عدم توفره سببه مو ارتفاع
عدد الاصابات بالسكري وانما سببه انه في
ناس ثانيه داخله على الخط وبدات تستخدم
العلاج وهذول هم الراغبين في انقاص
اوزانهم الابر اللي بنتكلم عنها اسمها
وزنبل معتمده لعلاج السكري وفيها نقص في
دول كثيره في العالم وتحديد كمان حتى في
امريكا في هذه الابر في هجوم عليها من
الراغبين في النحافه كنا بتسبب انقاص
الوزن وبالتالي بدا المصابين بالسكري ما
يلاقوا الدواء ومع البحث اكتشفنا شيء ثاني
كمان فالشركه المنتجه لهذه الابر الشهيره
حول العالم ابره ثانيه اسمها ويجوها هذه
الابر مكونها هو نفس مكون
وانما بجرعه اعلى وهذه الابر اصلا ابر
مخصصه لعلاج السم ولا تصرف الا بوصفه طبيب
لكن هذه الابر غاليه وجديده نسبيه فكميه
تصنيعها مو عاليه نسبيه هذا غير مشاكل في
سلاسل الامدادات هذه كلها مشاكل عملت نقص
في توفر وجوفي والنقص وصل لدرجه انه
الشركه بتنشر بيانات عنه على موقعها
وبتوعد الناس بزياده في التصنيع هذه السنه
فهذا الشيء خل الراغبين في انقاص اوزانهم
ويروحوا لذنبك لانها ببساطه فيها نفس
الماده الفعاله ونفس المفعول اللي بيخلل
الوزن وانما بجرعه اقل امام هذه الازمه
مرض السكري يا اما مضطرين ياخذوا جرعات
اقل من الموصوف لهم او جالسين بيحاولوا
الابر اخرى ما لها نفس الفعاليه عموما من
الموضوع زمتك هذه بيثير اسئله كثير جدا عن
علاج السمنه بالابر ومين اللي المفروض
ياخذ هذه الابر وكاف وهل هذه الابر تحديد
ان الناس جلسه بتاخذها لها اعراض جانبيه
مثلا ولا هي فعلا علاج
للوزن الزائد خلينا نحاول نفهم هذا
الموضوع وكل ما يخصه من مختص فمعنى من
الخبر دكتور وليد البكر استشاري السكري
والغدد الصماء اهلا فيك معنا دكتور وليد
خليني في البدايه بس اسالك كيف صار هذا
التحول انه من ابر بتستخدم في علاج السكري
صار فيك اكتشاف انه الموضوع برده له علاقه
بالسمنه
او في مساء الخير عليكم
في تنزيل
اوكي شركات المصنعه تصنع منها مكونات
تساعد في تنزيل الوزن وتسوق كعلاج الوزن
طبعا
وهناك ايضا
ادويه اخرى همم
هي عباره للسكر
دول فيكتوزه تطور الى نسبه دواء اسمه وهو
دور للوزن ومرتبه الدوليه للوزن اما
الاوزمبك فهو طبعا الان حاليا الدواء
معتمد للسكر وطور منه الى ان يصبح دواء
اسمه وجوبي اللي موجود الان في امريكا
ومجاز فيه الامريكيه كعلاج للسمنه طيب هذه
حقيقه تتقاطع مع علاج السكر بانه لها فنيه
بازال الوزن همم
اكثر على مرضى السكر انه نقصهم العلاج
بنسبه كبيره كون من السمنه مشكله صحيه
الان منتشره في المملكه وفي العالم بشكل
وهذا اللي يزاد الطلب عليها بشكل كبير جدا
صراحه يعني دكتور الفتره الاخيره انا ما
بسال احد باقول له انت كيف نحفت اللي
بيقول لي اوزمبك اخذت ابر وذنبك طيب همم
يعني هذا المفروض علاج لمرض محدد يعني
ايش نقدر نقول لما بياخذوه الناس اللي هم
بس عندهم مشكله عاديه في الوزن انه ساعات
هي بس كم كيلو بدهم ينزلوها ايش ممكن يكون
بيصير لهم
هذا الشيء كلام مهم جدا انه اساس علاج
الوزن يبدا بالحميه والرياضه هذا هو
الاساس بالاشياء همم ولكن احيانا عندما
تفشل الحميه والرياضه ويكون الوزن في
المعدلات العاليه بمعنى ان الكتله الجسم
تكون اعلى من 30
شخص كتله الجسم تبعه اكثر من 27 معه وجود
قابلين الثقه او القصه فهنا تنطبق عليه
استخدام الوزن ولا يفضل استخدام العشوائي
اللي يحصل الاسد باخذ عشوائيا بدون تقييم
الطبيب وبدون تحاليل وبدون متابعه دقيقه
على المدى الطويل
بدل فعاليه
هذه الفكره الاساسيه انه كل شيء لازم يكون
مع طبيب لازم كل شيء يكون فيه مراجعه كل
هذا الكلام طيب الناس نحنا عارفين بيروحوا
بيجيبوا بيشتروا وبيدوا نفسهم الابره مره
في الاسبوع
الوزن همم بالنسبه قليله جدا واحد بالالف
قد تحصل التهابات في البنكرياس وهذه نادره
همم احيانا تؤثر على النفسيه الشخص او
تزيقه الاكتئاب احيانا ولهذا هناك اشياء
معينه معينه الطبيعي يتاكد لا توجد هناك
موانع من الاستخدامها وايضا
المريض على ذلك همم قبل ان تحصل المضاعفات
احيانا باستخدامها
دكتور وليد لو انا جيتك وقلت لك والله
دكتور وليد عندي ثلاثه كيلو ابغى انزلهم
لو عملت لي الفحوصات ولقيت كل شيء انه
تمام عادي تعطيني اذنبك
هي الاساس طبعا هنا يعني هذه ال ال كميه
الكيلوات الزائده قليله جدا فم حقيقيه ما
تصل مرحله انك تاخذ الابر وتعرض نفسك
لمضاعفات الابر من ناحيه الغثيان والتعب
او قد
روحت فاذا كانت نسبه وزن بسيطه
اما اذا كانت نسبه عاليه وفشل الانسان
بالرياض الحميه هنا يكون في ممكن نستخدمها
لها بعدها دقيقه طبعا اوكي اذن بالمبدا
يعني فعلا ممكن اللجوء لها كعلاج ولكن يجب
مراجعه الطبيب اولا وطبعا لازم يكون فعلا
فيه وزن زايد احنا بنتكلم كثير بس انت
الاعراض اللي بتتكلم عنا الدكتور كمان في
نفس الوقت بعض الناس ممكن يقول لك طب ما
اتحملها عادي عادي امشيها اسبوعين ونزله
لكم كيلو واخلص يعني
في في هناك بعض الاشياء المهمه انا طبعا
بنعالج السمنه او زياده الوزن او البدانه
نعالجك مشكله صحيه ليست مشكله جماليه
بمعنى احيانا الوزن اذا زاد باثر على
الركب الانسان على ظهره فعلا على
ايضا الدهون الكبد على قابليه
الداخليه
المنفعه اذا كانت اكثر من مضره فلا باس
بالاخرها اذا كان المنفعه عاليه من نزول
الوزن على مستوى صحي والنفسي
والميكانيكي في الجسم
الواحد تتحسن نفسيته لما ينحفوشه شكله
احلى ههه هذه تاخذها بعين الاعتبار ممكن
المشكله ان الوزن الان مطلب جمال ايضا
يعني راح على كل الاجناس وهذا طبعا يجعل
هناك طلب كبير وهذا يجعل النقص الكبير
والطلب العالي على ان في بعض الناس ما وصل
مرحله يعني احتياج الابره ولكن ياخذونها
من اجل المطلب الوزن مثالي
كثير صراحه انا اعرفهم دكتور يعني فعليا
بيلجاوا الان لهذه الابره بس السؤال هو
كمان اللي بيطرح نفسه اذا هو هذا علاج
محدد لمرضى السكري وان تذكرت انه يعني في
ادويه او ابر ثانيه تستخدم للسمنه وما الى
ذلك كيف هذا
النوع من الادويه
تنباع او بتنصرف من غير وصفات طبيه يعني
عادي
لا الان طبعا وزاره الصحه السعوديه طبعا
صرف الاوزميلك هو بيكون وصفه طبيه
الناس الي عندهم سكر في المملكه وطبعا
احنا
عارفينها
في العالم فيها
بتنصرف من غير وصفات الناس ما شاء الله
صاروا بيبعثوها لبعض حول العالم
المملكه
انه صح ينحفك ولكنك مضطر انك تاخذ هذه
الابره مدى الحياه علشان مستويات السكر في
الجسم وما الى ذلك هل هذا الكلام صحيح
طبعا السمنه هي مرض مزمن تبقى مع انسان
دائما انه عملها زي معامله السكر
عشان كم كيلو
في حدود الرقم العالي اللي يسبب اثر
ميكانيكي وصحي على الجسم
شهر هل لازم بعد الشهر يستمروا ياخذوها
واللي عادي يوقفوها وما راح يصير شيء
طبعا هذا استخدام يعني انا ما اوصي فيه
ابدا انزل الوزن الطبيعي يوقف ويكمل
اوكي طيب احنا بنشكرك على هذه التوضيحات
وهذه المداخله كان معنا من الخبر دكتور
وليد البكر استشاري السكري والغدد الصماء
شكرا لك دكتور
[موسيقى]
لسه موجودين في قوائم اهتمامات الناس حول
العالم هذه الايام والسبب تطورات قصتهم
وتبادل ردات الفعل فمن بعد ما طرحت شاكيرا
اغنيتها اللي قلبت الدنيا والمشاهدات
واعتبرت انتقام موسيقي للنجمه من شركه
السابقه للفصلت عنه بعد عشر سنوات بسبب
خيانه لها مع فتاه عمرها 23 سنه فغنت
شاكيرا وقالت كثير وقليل ولكن من ابرز ما
قالته بدلت الفيراري بتونجو
كاسونج
يمتص الصدمه والصفه القويه هذه ويحولها
لمكسبنا كيف راح اعلن عن التعاقد معه شركه
كاسيو وطلع مدح في ساعاتهم وقال هذه ساعات
تدوم مدى الحياه وهذا الرجل يبدو انه ما
كان الوحيد في جعبه اللاعب بعد فيديو
كاسيو شفنا هذا الفيديو لوصوله لمقر
الدوري
مثل ما شفته في الفيديو وصل يعني لمقر
دوري كنز بالسيارات وينجو وهي السياره
اللي بتصنعها رينو وشبهت شاكيرا صاحبه
بيكي الجديده فيها في الاغنيه لما قالت له
بدل فراري
وبيكي رد بانه ظهر سائق تونجو طيب الدراما
مو موقفه هنا ولا مقتصره على الثنائي
السابق في الموضوع دخلت فيه كمان
شاكيرا اللي بالمناسبه هي وام جيران مشغل
الاغنيه على العالي للنهار كمان حاطه على
البلكونه المواجهه المنزل
لا لا لا لا
[موسيقى]
[تصفيق]
في تقرير
الساحره وتوقف الاغاني والمشاكيرا عموما
علاقه الثنائي من زمان
انه يعني الام كانت معاهده علاقتهم كون
شاكيرا اكبر من ابنها باكثر من 10 سنين
وكانت شايفه انه شاكيرا مهتمه بمسيرتها
الغنائيه اكثر من ابنها هذا غير انها من
وقت ما ابناء صاحب البنت الجديده
وارقامها القياسيه الاغنيه صار عليها اكثر
من 100 24 مليون
واحد وعمرها 45 وبعدين سنه وبغنيه
بالاسباني وقالت انه هذه الاغنيه كانت
منفذ وراح لها وانه نفسها تحضن كل نساء
العالم اللي بيساندوا وبيدافعوا عن بعض
امور نساء اللي بيحطموا وبيحسسوا بعض انهم
مو مهمين طبعا يعني لاحظتوا الدقه هنا
رجعت في الفستان كمان شاكيرا وقالت انها
مو مصدقه انه اغنيتها صارت اسرع اغنيه
اسبانيه في التاريخ بتحقق هذه المشاهدات
على يوتيوب وقالت محتاجه احد يقرصني علشان
اصدق
[موسيقى]
النصر وما ادراك لمن يكون فايق ورايق
ويقرر يحلل عاد في تويتر مو يحل المزايا
ولا اوضاع موظفين ولا سياسات المنصه لا
قرر يحلل علاقه تويتر بالنفس البشريه لا
اقارن كمان
فهو نشر تغريده قال فيها انه تويتر بسبب
للناس الغضب وانستغرام بسبب للناس
الاكتئاب وسائل الناس برايكم ايهما احسن
موضوع الانستغرام
يعني انا صراحه مثلا من الناس اللي كل هذه
الاشياء الانستغرام وتويتر بس برده ههه
عموما في احد الردود في شخص قال لي ماسك
انه تويتر ما بيعصبه ابدا بالعكس
الاسطول النهار بيضحك على تويتر ونصحه انه
للتخلص من الغضب انه يلغي متابعه مراسلين
والسياسيين
والاعلاميين ورد عليه ال الماسك وقال له
صحيح انا بضحك كمان كثير على تويتر
من وقت رجوع الطالبان للسلطه في افغانستان
وشغلهم الشغل المراه وقرارات ضد حقوقها
وحرياتها وحرمان من العمل وحرمان من
التعليم وحرمان من الوظائف وفصل بين
النساء والرجال في المنتزهات يعني ايام
النساء وايام للرجال وغير كثير من
القرارات اللي كلها ضد المراه وحرياتها
ولكن اخر قرار غريب عجيب حتى انه يعني
الملكانات الستات ما خلصوا منهم يعني
فطالبان امرت بقطع رؤوس الملكات في واجهات
المحلات التجاريه في تجار طبعا ما اعجبهم
هذا الكلام وما حبوا انه يمثلوا وقالوا
يعني انه منظر بلا رؤوس مرعبه وراح يطفش
الزبائن قرروا التحايل على القرار
بالتغطيه وجوه الملكه
[موسيقى]
ماشي يا دينا احنا وصلنا الى ختام حلقه
اليوم انا عد والقاكم غدا ان شاء الله في
حلقه جديده من تفاعلكم في امان الله
[موسيقى]